as fun as the holidays are they can
leave a dirty reminder on your carpet
your tile your Upholstery and now that
we're in the new year it is time to call
the experts at Zerorez to get your home
back to clean and healthy joining us
with more our co-owners Doug and Ben
McKee welcome you guys thanks for having
us it's good to be back into the new
year where you get things settled you
clean up after the holidays you you get
all those people out of your house but
then they leave you with dirty carpets
so why should they call zero Rose you
know we are here to help clean up your
home and make it a healthy hygienic
space and we do it with our incredible
ZR water technology that cleans out
cleans any other soap or surfactant out
there and it keeps your carpets cleaner
longer I tell everybody about your
method with the zero water because it's
just water that cleans and you don't
have that residue afterwards exactly I
mean if if you imagine like taking
shampoo putting it in your hair and then
trying to vacuum it out that's exactly
exactly what traditional carpet cleaning
methods are doing it's going to leave a
mess in your carpet and it may look good
temporarily but eventually all that soil
all the sticky residue from the soap is
going to cause your carpets to resoil
and zero res none of that is an issue I
noticed that the carpets
stronger they
just stir and let's
let's stains are really hard to get out
they could be a doozy and you know we as
humor as we approach with actually
trying to address the stain and removing
the cause of the odor a lot of companies
they just try to put out a deodorizer
and say oh it's taken care of it yeah
all right we could have a one-two punch
approach to it so that your home again
is returned to a healthy hygienic State
and most of the times you can actually
help reverse those stains so that you
don't even know what happened I love
that let's do a demo here Doug like you
guys are always bringing in
I'm filthy and you do it I call it the
one swiper and it's amazing what can
happen all right let's give it a swipe
it's a strong vacuum if we can get the
rug to stay still there we go oh my God
so you can see I'm in it it looks so
effortless but I'm covering up the you
can still still that's crazy so this
this vacuum the reason why this is so
powerful this is actually hooked up to
the truck's engine that we have outside
and it's like having a 300 horsepower
vacuum and coupled with our hot ZR water
I mean we're talking at the truck the
water's about 230 degrees Fahrenheit it
is just eliminating the dirt and the
residue that's already in that carpet so
you're left with clean carpets that as
we said it stays cleaner longer we love
that and you guys always offer a special
you are offering this year's special
your carpet cleaned for as low as 35
dollars per room plus you will get a
hallway clean for free so give zero res
a call thank you zero rest for
sponsoring the segment you can reach
them at
702-840-333 or just go online at
zerorezlasvegas.com for more minimums of
five
Las Vegas now we'll be right back